there is something about us that causes
us to a dict
to everything we addicted territory and
then we'll kill to defend it we
addicting
if any of you have ever been
unexpectedly left by a sexual partner
the symptoms of that are exactly like
the symptoms of withdrawal from heroin
me you burst into tears unexpectedly you
vomit every few hours you hide in
darkened rooms you can't face people you
don't want to go anywhere you you are
withdrawing and it's exactly the same
thing we add it to each other then we
addicted to all forms of behavior to
routine you know ludwig von bertalanffy
with founder of general Systems Theory
said human beings are not machines but
in every case where they are given the
opportunity to behave like machines they
will choose to do so so did this and
this is why we need an external input to
dissolve our programming we apparently
evolved with this need and in societies
where psychedelics are not available
poor substitutes have have been put in
place
starvation flagellation sonic driving oh
I don't know
complicated visualizations and so forth
these are stopgap measures to try to ass
wage and direct this this virulent need
of ours to a dick to something well when
you take the tendency to a dick to
behaviors and cultural modes and so
forth and weld it to the demonic
capacity of modern technology to produce
more powerful drugs than have ever been
known before and in greater amounts so
that laboratories can produce literally
tens of millions of doses of cocaine or
heroin can could be produced in rural
laboratories in Burma or Colombia and
then you have a global transportation
and delivery system that within 24 hours
can have this stuff on the street in
Frankfurt
Bangkok Tokyo it means that we have to
take hold of ourselves and realize what
is going on the dark side of ourselves
married to technology can just carry us
to hell in a handbasket without any
difficulty at all if we don't quickly
and radically revise our relationship to
these things so
the issue strangely enough which lies
directly ahead of us on the historical
continuum is in fact the issue of drugs
and more broadly the issue of addiction
what we are doing to ourselves
unexamined habitual behavior patterns
and after all isn't that what we object
to about hard drugs
isn't that what is so offensive about
the anything addict the heroin addict
the television addict the thing addict
is that when it comes time for their fix
whether it be st. elsewhere or whatever
do not stand in these people's way you
know they are going for the button they
are going for the syringe whatever it is
[Music]